oh
hey everybody how are you jack here
what is the meaning of this
i'm sorry what was your name ps
well miss pierce and please don't tell
me it's mrs pierce and break my heart
this train doesn't belong to you so why
don't you turn around and face me
pumpkin
this train was commended legally under
the holy
nut balls
what happened to your freaking face
don't get killed
guns i got them you need them
later
okay how about this
lady i don't even know what to call you
you tell me why you look like you
headbutted a belt sander and i'll let
all you go right now
my husband gave me a skag pearl ring the
pearl released hunger-inducing
pheromones oh you know what
i am so sorry i i just forgive me
where's your husband now
he's dead
that is a heartbreaker
but
you've got something in common with them
now at least
oh
mm-hmm
oh
holy crap did you see your head it was
like
oh my god we'll help
a real shame
please return the echoes to me whenever
you're capable of doing so
you